hi martin what's up
hi dina
i heard you've made one of our company's
internal web apps serverless on google
cloud platform uh pete in the ops team
said that it's much easier to manage
that app now that it's serverless
oh yeah and it was pretty easy to move
it and because it's serverless now it
requires less ops work to keep it going
oh good
so our company's web app for gathering
user feedback is starting to get more
traffic now that life is returning to
normal
and the app went down yesterday and i'm
starting to feel overwhelmed by the ops
work required to keep it running and
restarting it and everything
could you help me make it serverless i
would love to let's do it
[Music]
all right
i remember hearing about the user
feedback web app
we use it to ask our customers questions
right
yep and let's see here it is
here's a sample question asking
customers what lollipop flavor we should
release next
oh gosh who's voting for kale ugh
anyway
how does the app work
so it's a container that runs on a
virtual machine which is backed by a
mongodb database instance in the cloud
oh yeah i remember moving that mongodb
instance to the cloud a couple of years
ago
right and back in 2019 the app got a lot
more traffic after our new product hit
the stores uh so it crashed and no one
was around to restart the virtual
machine so it remained down for a few
days and we can't have that happen again
oh my gosh i remember that oh
also
aren't you paying for that virtual
machine 24 7.
yeah that's the other thing sometimes we
get a lot of traffic and the app needs
more than one virtual machine but
sometimes no one is using it for days at
a time and we run many virtual machines
for this app one for production one for
staging a few for development
and it's expensive to pay for all those
idle servers or to sign someone to turn
them on and off when they aren't needed
oh i completely agree
okay let's start by determining whether
or not your app is a good fit for
serverless hosting and i have a
checklist
oh that sounds great
okay item number one
is your application a web app
yes it is
ah excellent okay item number two
is your application
containerized
yes it sure is
oh great okay item number three
is the container stateless
that is
it doesn't store user sessions and ram
between requests or anything like that
uh yeah there are no user sessions or
all the user sessions are are stored in
the database all the data is in the
database nothing in temporary variables
or anything like that perfect
okay this sounds like a good fit for
cloud run because it is a stateless web
app
in a container
app engine is a great fit for web apps
but it doesn't use containers
and honestly this sounds a little too
complex for cloud functions
oh okay let's deploy it on cloud run
then yes
the one moment one note to be clear i
just wanna be clear the application
doesn't have to be in a stateless
container right now to move it to cloud
run but it would require more steps if
it weren't on the other hand your use
case is very straightforward so let's do
it let's deploy your existing container
to cloud run
okay let's see i'm going to cloud run
here in the console
i click here to create a new service
i give it a name
and region
i pick my existing container from the
container registry
uh okay so far so good uh but dina
doesn't the container need to be adapted
somehow for cloud run
it does
great question
i've moved a few web apps from virtual
machines to cloud run and i've created a
short checklist for it
ah you really do like checklists don't
you dina
guilty as charged i love them okay here
it is
variables and secrets
connections
security and trigger
let's start with the first item
click advanced settings and then
variables and secrets
click add variable
and then you just add all the
environment variables that your
container expects
got it so the virtual machine has five
environment variables that are used by
the container
yeah you're just going to copy all of
those to cloud run
but not
the port variable because cloudrun does
that for you
okay
give me a
minute all right
uh okay so uh what's this secret
sections here
if there are some environment variables
that are extra sensitive like passwords
you can put them in google cloud's
secret manager that way you get
fine-grained permissions per secret
audit logs of who reads and writes the
secrets and versioning of the secrets
it's
pretty useful
yeah that does sound pretty useful
but i don't want to update the code in
my container and re-test the container
and rebuild the container oh that's okay
you don't have to if you've already
defined these as environment variables
in your container you can use the cloud
run configuration to expose the secrets
from secret manager as environment
variables
oh
that sounds great
i will check that out later
for now let's just keep it simple i will
use these normal environment variables i
have here sounds good
the next item on my checklist is
connections
does your container connect to any
virtual machines in a virtual private
cloud or vpc
yes it does connect to that mongodb
virtual machine and that one only has an
internal ip address it's not visible on
the external
public internet got it
okay so that mongodb virtual machine
sits in a virtual private cloud when
your container was also running on a
virtual machine it was in the vpc and it
could connect to the mongodb by default
for cloud run we need to add that vpc
connection
so
you're going to click connections
then create a serverless vpc connector
then create connector
go ahead and give it a name under subnet
pick custom ip range
and then enter that default that they're
showing there 10.8.0.0
click create
and the new connector will be available
in a minute or two okay
i did all that
uh okay let's wait for it
okay once the connector has been created
go back to the cloud run page and
refresh that list of vpc connectors
now pick the one that you just created
all right very good
done
uh okay so that was number two on your
four item uh checklist uh what's the
next one
ah the next one is security
okay well as you know dina security is
important to our company uh how should i
set up strong security
you should always use the principle of
least privilege this container should
only have the minimum privileges needed
to do its job and no more
you could run this container as the
default compute engine service account
but that account has more permissions
than your container needs so go to the
security tab and click create new
service account
okay
i see that the system here suggested a
name for this new service account it
looks like it's based on the name of the
cloud run service
that's nice that'll make it easier to
keep track of things
uh i'm clicking create here
uh oh should i grant it any additional
permissions here
does your container access any other
google cloud products
no it only accesses that mongodb
instance okay then there's no need to
grant additional permissions
and that's good this is a good thing if
a co-worker of ours accidentally adds
code to the container that tries to
access
any other resource in this project
it will fail
and that is safer for everybody
yeah that does feel good
uh okay so far so good uh what's the
fourth item on your checklist
it's trigger so we need to configure how
the service is triggered so go ahead and
click that section and we'll walk
through it
okay done
first you need to set which networks can
access the service
if it's a public web app you want to
pick allow all traffic
okay so i'm leaving that as it is
what are the two other radio buttons for
dina the second radio button allow
internal traffic and traffic from cloud
load balancing is for apps that get
their traffic from another internal
application or via a load balancer
you need to put a load balancer in front
of your service to use cloud armor for
protection or identity aware proxy for
authentication
got it and the third radio button oh
that one's useful if your service is an
internal microservice that should only
be reachable by other services in your
project if you pick that option your
service will not be visible to the
public internet
ah got it
let's see the next section here says
authentication uh what should i pick
there
well this app is public so you should
stick to the first radio button
ah okay
i'll do that uh but but what would
happen if i picked the second radio
button well then only service accounts
which have the cloud run invoker
permission would be able to trigger your
service and the public wouldn't be able
to use it at all
oh got it is that it
yes
click the create button
oh all right
clicking it now
okay let's wait for the deployment to
finish
all right
it looks like the deployment is done
that was quick uh and what now
cloudron has given your new service a
url do you see it there in the cloud
console uh oh there it is i'm clicking
it
and there it is your existing container
running serverlessly in cloud run
as a side note if you wanted a different
url for your service you could set that
up by clicking custom domain
nice and the application is working
so to recap what was your checklist for
moving an existing container
serverlessly to cloudrun
okay first check what environment
variables your container is using and
enter them in the cloud run user
interface
you can also set them from the command
line with the gcloud command
for sensitive data consider putting them
in secret manager for added security and
auditing
and you can still access these values as
environment variables so you won't have
to edit the code inside your container
okay
then if your container accesses servers
within a virtual private cloud like a
database for instance
set up a serverless vpc connector to the
vpc where your server lives
got it
after that is security create a new
service account that has the minimum
privileges needed to let the container
do its job
configure cloud run to use that new
service account
uh yeah i remember doing that
and finally we need to configure how the
service is triggered if it's a public
web app pick allow all traffic
if your app gets traffic from the google
cloud load balancer you'd pick that
option
and if your service is an internal only
service that should not be reachable
from the public internet pick the option
for that
excellent this checklist will make it a
lot easier to move other containers to
cloud run so i don't have to maintain
those pesky servers
and you get auto scaling with cloud run
so if the thousands of customers want to
vote on our next candy flavor
the container will automatically be
deployed to more instances
and bonus
you're not paying for it when it's not
in use
that sounds like the best kind of flavor
to me
thank you everyone for watching if you
have questions for me or dina about
moving containers to cloud run please
let us know in the comments also if you
have suggestions for future videos
please enter them below
bye
[Music]
you